- I am so excited to
introduce our next guest.
I am so thrilled that she is here.
She is a philanthropist,
a UN Messenger of Peace,
mother,
award winning actor who
is currently right now,
in one of the top Netflix
films of all times,
"The Old Guard."
Ladies and gentlemen,
it's Charlize Theron.
(audience applauding)
- Hi.
(screaming)
I'm probably gonna have to redo the intro
because of my lifelong lisp.
I'm like Netflix (mumbles)
It's the best thing on Netflix.
- You better not touch that.
That is what we love about you.
So do not touch that.
- Whenever I see someone parody me
which I'm always like so excited that I...
Anyone would even know who
I am, let alone parody me.
It's always like the
craziest face of the lisp.
(laughing)
And I'm just like dying,
laughing.
I'm like, "It's true."
- Oh my God the way
you just did that face,
that's amazing.
- If someone was gonna do you
they would just get
taller, and more beautiful,
and more worldly, and
philanthropic, and smart.
It's true.
- That's not true.
Once I did "Monster"
everything I did after that
there were like,
"Oh, another ugly movie,
another ugly movie."
And SNL did a skit
where literally it was just
like me walking around,
trying to look like a baby's
arm growing out of my head.
(laughing)
Just trying to be
as uncomfortable looking as possible.
And I was like, "Guys, I
did one movie like that.
"Stop it."
- We have a friend in common.
And you even mentioned
this in your Oscar speech.
This man, Steve Warren.
- Yes.
I remember I said my lawyer, Steve Warren.
I heard just like
snickering in the audience.
Like, "Wait, you can't think your lawyer."
And I was like, "He's my friend."
(chuckles)
He's amazing.
And I don't have to tell you this.
He's changed my life.
I think all of the beautiful things
that I have in my life today,
Steve somehow has something to do with it.
- We actually have
something in common too,
which is I've heard you're on
a break from relationships.
- Yeah.
- And I'm so in love
with my children.
I have this love in my
life that's so impactful.
And I've spent my life
trying to figure out men
for 45 years.
I'm like, "I'm tired, I'm bored.
"It's all about the kids."
- Yeah.
I completely know what you're saying.
And it is strange for people
to kind of wrap their heads around it.
I've been on a few dates,
but I haven't dated anybody
for over five years.
(exclaims)
- Me too.
- Yeah, so we have a lot in common.
So, I'm open when
friends of mine are like,
"You should go on a date,
you should meet this guy."
Like I'm always open.
But it is like,
I feel like I'm in a place in my life
where you gotta come with a lot of game.
Not the kind of game that we think of,
the kind of game that's
like my life is really good,
so you better be able to
bring that and maybe better.
'Cause I just won't to
accept anything less.
And my life with my children,
and with my incredible adopted
family that I have around me,
I don't long for that much.
I don't really long...
I can honestly say this on my life,
I don't feel lonely.
Once I had my children,
it's not that it replaces something,
or that it makes you less
interested in something else,
like I'm still...
I was just two seconds
ago talking about a dude
that I thought was really hot.
I'm still firing in all cylinders,
I just...
I think your priorities are in a place
that is of high demand, right?
'Cause it's a lot of work to be a parent.
And then part of that
is at the end of the day
I get in bed and I go,
"My God, I wouldn't want this
day to be anything different.
- Yup.
I always say I would want
someone to be an addition
if not the equation and
never a subtraction.
- That's...
You said it.
I did the poor man's line of that.
Thank you for...
I'm gonna take that.
I'm stealing that just so you know.
- It's for both of us
since we're both on such a similar path,
and Jackson is eight?
- Yes.
- And August is five?
- Yes
- I have Olive who's eight this
month and Frankie who's six.
- Wow, we're so close.
- I know.
I never realized our kids
were that aligned in ages.
- Yes.
Super, super close.
I had an idea we were close,
but I didn't know we were that close.
- Oh, well gosh, darn the pandemic.
I would be like, "How are
we getting our kids together
"when things ease up?"
I would love nothing more.
The more--
- Yes, the same year.
- Oh please.
And my kids, it's so hard
for kids with the adjustments
and God bless all of them
for being as adaptable
and sane as some of them are.
I just...
It makes me marvel at their
capacity and adaptability.
How are your kids right now?
- My mind is blown by that as well.
I have to tell you,
there's a part of all of this
that's so devastating, right?
Like we are really truly
living in a whole new world.
And when I look at my children
and how they're just
adapting to it so well.
This...
Just the idea,
like the other day I
walked out of the house
and I had to walk back into the house
'cause I forgot my mask.
And I realized my children
don't forget their masks.
They literally always
have their masks on them.
I'm like, I'm the one that always like,
I walk out, I gotta go back in and get...
They have just embraced
that this is what their
world is right now.
And I have to say even the homeschooling,
when we went into that first lockdown,
it was really, really hard
because they're kids, right?
And so they just don't fully comprehend
but by now they figured out,
"Okay, this is what it is."
And it's like, it's really different.
They've kind of embraced this now.
And they still can share
that they miss their friends,
and that they miss going to school.
But at the same time they're
just not dwelling on it,
which is just so incredible.
It's like, they're just moving on with it.
(bright upbeat music)